hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein tolles basic video ich
zeige euch heute wie man frucht einlagen
machen kann fragen sich wahrscheinlich
viele was sind überhaupt frucht einlagen
und zwar ist es eine einlage die er in
für torten verwenden könnt ich verwende
ganz gerne frucht einlagen in torten
weil man die gut vorbereiten kann um hat
einfach 100 prozent frucht in der torte
ohne dass aber die früchte schlecht
werden das heißt ihr könnt die so
haltbar machen wenn ich zum beispiel
eine torte mechanische torte mit bananen
da muss man ja die torte schon am
gleichen tag oder am nächsten tag essen
weil die bahnen dann einfach immer so
ein bisschen braun werden oder wenn ich
erdbeeren nehme wenn ein bisschen
matschig und deswegen nehmen wir am
besten frucht einlagen die könnt ihr
toll vorbereiten ihr könnt sie
einfrieren und habt immer frucht
einlagen auf vorrat und vor allem könnt
ihr wirklich fast jedes obst und jede
frucht benutzen
ich zeige euch heute jetzt zwei
verschiedene varianten und ich zeige
euch auch eine ganz gelingt sichere
variante zu schauen so jander zuschauen
wie die fu einlage nicht ganz eben
gesagt habe jedenfalls werde ich jetzt
eine blaue box einlage machen und am
sichersten ist es immer so dass er die
früchte nehmt also ich habe jetzt hier
frucht glaube die sind jetzt tief
gefroren aber ihr könnt auch frische
früchte verwenden wenn sie gerade saison
haben
ansonsten empfehle ich euch immer nimmt
tiefgekühlte denn die werden erntereif
direkt eingefahren das war das wort was
mir gefehlt hat ich nehme blau werden
weil die dort als die frucht anlage
kommt in die torte und die kleine ella
naef blaubeeren über alles genau und
reife früchte sind ganz wichtig weil sie
einfach den vollen geschmack haben und
vor allem sind sie eben aus der region
dann meist weil sie im saisonal
gepflückt werden
ganz wichtig ist jetzt dass jetzt die
früchte püriert werden und die genaue
mengenangaben schreibe ich euch einfach
auf den block und zeigt euch jetzt wie
ich vorgehen
ich brauche nur durch die früchte ein
bisschen wasser unten bindemittel und
ich nehme als bindemittel immer ganz
gerne agile agar agar das ist die
pflanzliche variante zusteller schiene
so könnt ihr das ganze nämlich
garn zu bereiten und die früchte werden
eingekocht und dafür muss ich jetzt
vorher pürieren
jetzt werden die früchte probiert
entweder im mixer oder mit stabmixer zum
beispiel diesen jetzt noch ein bisschen
arg gefroren deswegen gebe ich ein
bisschen wasser rein also am besten gut
aufbauen lassen
so wie ich es jetzt mache sie zwar
zuerst einmal kompliziert aus nur fragen
wieso macht es nicht auf einmal ob ich
erkläre ich werde zuerst einmal die
blaubeeren nehmen also das püree und
wird es jetzt einkochen lassen
jedes obst und jede frucht hat ja in
anderen wassergehalt und jetzt könnt ihr
im konkret hier die ak tine mit
reingeben zwei minuten sport und
aufkochen lassen und die masse welt
fertig aber so wie ich das jetzt gleich
mache ich lasse das die blau beim
einkochen dass die feuchtigkeit die
flüssigkeit verdunstet und werdet diarra
tine separat mit dem wasser aufkochen
und zwar deswegen da könnt ihr einfach
besser einschätzen wie viel flüssigkeit
ihr verwendet weil es bei einem blauen
band ja wenn es nicht so viel
flüssigkeit anderes obst andere früchte
haben noch mehr flüssigkeit und einem
zug findet es eben am besten einschätzen
also die globalen werden jetzt zuerst
einmal vier bis fünf minuten eingekocht
bis fast die komplette flüssigkeit
verdunstet und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich hier schon mal die agile zwei
minuten sprudelnd aufkochen lassen ist
auch ganz wichtig damit sie einfach ihre
wirkung entfalten
also die akademie jetzt schon fertig und
die blauen sind fast so weit also man
sieht wenn das trophy eingedeckt ist das
einfach diese bläschen immer kleiner
werden weil einfach die masse dicker
wird
so steht dem mars aus richtig schön
dickflüssig und dafür ich jetzt die
aktie mit rein
man könnte jetzt natürlich auch zucker
mit einbringen damit die frucht anlage
ein bisschen süßer wird
aber mir geht es dann wirklich nur darum
die frucht zu 100 prozent in die torte
zu bekommen und ich rühre dann den
zucker lieber in die creme und in den
teig mit einem und es lasse jetzt ganz
kurzen raum abkühlen
während die heute bei frucht ein lager
noch abkühlen zeige ich euch noch eine
andere variante
man kann ja auch obst mischen oder ihr
könnt zum beispiel auch ein bisschen
liköre oder anderen geschmack mit
reinbringen zitronenschale orangensaft
oder was auch immer ich nehme es mal als
beispiel die bananen den bananen haben
wir nicht so viel feuchtigkeit
da ist es ein bisschen anders dann
müsste die banane nämlich abwägen und
bei den heidelbergern habe ich so
gemacht dass am ende 300 gramm
heidelbeer gerät da ist also eingekocht
und bei den männern musste hat man so
direkt 300 gramm nehmen wir ein bisschen
weniger und nehme jetzt noch eine birne
mit dazu
jetzt habe ich hier also etwa 300 gramm
obst was eben nicht so viel feuchtigkeit
enthält dann kommt ihr 200 milliliter
wasser mit rein und ist führe ich jetzt
kurz durch
das wort bewegt kommt jetzt auch in
einen topf und jetzt bei dieser variante
ist es eben so dass ich nicht auf zwei
mal aufgerufen sondern auf einmal
überleben das obst ist mit sehr wenig
flüssigkeit damit die bananen dennoch
nicht braun werden und auch ein bisschen
geschmack bekommt gebe ich noch ein
bisschen zitrone mit rein
das hebt den bananen geschmack noch ein
bisschen jetzt die ak tine und dann zwei
minuten
also die birnen bananen zuchtanlage ist
auch ein gekocht ohne zeig ich euch wie
man sie weiter verwendet ich mache es
mit der blaubär weiter weil die einfach
schon so ein bisschen lauwarm ist und
anfängt zu studieren
ihr müsst jetzt die buch anlage irgendwo
hinein gießen am besten eignet sich
natürlich tortenring die gibt es in
verschiedenen größen oder nehmen einen
verstellbaren tortenring den kann man
immer auf die richtige größe einstellen
wer jetzt keine torten ringe hat kann
natürlich trotzdem bucht einlagen machen
dafür nimmt er an zum beispiel tiefe
teller tassen oder sonst irgendwelche
runden gegenstände
wichtig ist jetzt nur dass ihr die
einlagen kleiner macht als die torte
selbst das heißt ich nehme jetzt 20 cm
durchmesser für eine torte dies aber 26
groß die einlage muss bisschen kleiner
sein damit man sie von außen eben nicht
sieht damit diese später gut
apfelkompott kommt jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen frischhaltefolie da kommt der
tortenring drauf aber das aus wisla
einschlagen
er wird zwei ringe eingeschlagen weil
ich zwei dünne frucht einlage platten
machen können doch eine dicke machen
dann wird es noch hier rein gefüllt
und dann einfach so ein bisschen
verteilen
damit es jetzt ganz gleichmäßig
verteilen können dass er auch so ein
bisschen klopfen und dann am besten
einfach für unfair 30 minuten ins
gefrierfach stellen
die frucht einlagen sind jetzt fest ich
zeigt ihr euch jetzt mal und da ich
selber auch nur einen tortenring habt
der kleiner ist also für die 20 cm torte
habt ihr in 12 cm tortenring genommen
und dann mache ich dann immer so dass
ich es einfach kurz fest werden lassen
im gefrierschrank den tod bringt
entferne und dann die anderen eben auch
noch machen und von der konsistenz her
sieht man diesen etabliert das heißt ich
was drauf und klebt auch nichts mehr
sie sind sehr reich also flexibel und
jetzt könnt ihr dies so für die torten
verwenden und so benutzen wenn ihr seid
aber ein flehen wollt könnt ihr es
natürlich auch tun und sie auf vorrat
zubereiten dann sind ganz feste platten
wenn sie die frauen sind und bin jetzt
die gefrorenen platten verwendet müsste
sie aber nicht auftauen lassen das heißt
ihr könnt ihr im gefrorenen zustand in
der torte mit reinsetzen mit creme über
decken usw
und wenn die dann später in der torte
ein bisschen anschauen dann wird die
torte auch nicht matschig dadurch weil
es einfach die ak tine eben bewirkt ja
und ich hoffe dass ich euch damit jetzt
eine gute idee geben konnte für eure
nächste fruchtige torte und im anschluss
hätte noch ein paar bilder wo ich eben
diese frucht einlagen benutzt habe und
alle weiteren infos findet ihr auf salis
- blog.de viel spaß beim nachmachen und
wissen nicht mal tschüss